foreign
solid snowflakes also Trivial Pursuit
peace Flakes and balls flakes show
doesn't know how to crystallize
correctly I suppose it all started with
the snow Jimmy Durant aeration also
she'll completely refuses to watch look
I'm not trying to get all political here
but can we really trust the US mail when
they carry their bags around gaping open
in a snowstorm with a male just hanging
out like this especially when it falls
on the day before Christmas
for when the first snow is also a
Christmas snow wait is it Christmas Day
or Christmas Eve day either way why are
these kids in school especially when
there's two feet of snow on the ground I
suppose this is when the Elder folk lean
over to the children and say something
like remember when drawing shapes on
fogged up Windows was exciting can't see
stage think they need the followers we
just needed condensation I've
I've had called the magician
should container today's class Christmas
party on a teacher's salary now
Professor Hinkle was just about the
worst magician in the world accidentally
exposing your deck and balls to a Grade
School class the eggs have turned into
um fried eggs since apparently animators
can't animate anything transparent it's
a clear problem they're bored has this
movie met children if this happened in a
real classroom these kids would most
certainly be pointing shouting and
laughing their Aces off right now this
kid apparently rides his sled to and
from school and since he's going up
hills I can only assume it also has an
invisible propulsion system you can keep
your levitating skateboard Back to the
Future I'll take the magical perpetual
motion sled
we're building a snowman not sure how
we'll get any further layers on since
this thing is already taller than we are
but hey if we have to sacrifice the life
of a friend or two to the gods of
Artistic integrity more game also can
someone build her some pants [ __ ]
winter people don't tell me these are
flesh toned stretch pants or something
this was 1969 and everything was made
from wool Tweed or shag carpet remnants
[Music]
I've always found the will to venture
out of my house to be the most difficult
part of building a snowman happy
birthday shows like this ask us to
believe that the proper response to a
suddenly sentient snow being is to
instantly adore it in reality every
square inch of snow would be yellow as
all these children piss themselves
screaming for their mothers
if that hat is Magic I want it back and
the children understanding that it was
his to begin with and to take it would
be stealing did the right thing and
allowed him to have it back the end
it's not yours anymore you threw it away
oh right kids also this would never hold
water in court he was performing and it
was entertainment no one is allowed to
hold us I mean him responsible for any
possible purposeful heirs we I mean he
might make while attempting to entertain
even more also yes we know there's some
well-documented animation weirdness
involving this girl's clothing during
the scene but we refuse to draw any more
attention to it and instead are going to
sin you for even knowing what we're
talking about well we sure did these two
talking used in so well that it sounds
like only one voice now of course oh
we're doing this again he's just going
to inkadinka do this narration for the
entire Jimmy duration of the show fine
the hat did belong to Frosty and the
children
that point must be made very clear
overstating your case me thinks the
Durante does protest too much happy
birthday
hey
I said my first words no you repeated
your first words from a few minutes ago
you cold-faced liar I can count to 10
and you can grow a fifth finger on just
this one occasion simply for this
display
I'm even ticklish but no one even
tickled you you're really starting to
freak me out man see kids back in my day
we would March in a line and that was
good enough nobody needed to talk a tick
or flick a fleet or do a do you gotta
love a town where the buildings are
generically labeled Grill restaurant and
hotel it's like living in the town-sized
version of the bottom cereal aisle with
fruit spins cocoa nuggets and buncho
cinnamon squares person distracted by a
curvy passerby runs into something
cliche
[Music]
this is not how mustaches work come on
come on kids follow the
Follow the Leader or frog because you
said Follow the Leader and if I
understand the rules of that game
correctly everyone should now be
crouched behind you like some sort of
snowman centipede
didn't see that traffic light what's a
traffic light New Yorkers
[Music]
oh Karen Karen's Karen's scarf keeps
glitching in and out of existence here
and I knew this was a matrix movie a
refrigerator generated box car
on a train headed north that otherwise
only includes an engine in a caboose
it's almost like it was made for this
convenient moment also Karen you are far
too knowledgeable about box cars I send
you are you coming to the North Pole too
I'm sure my mother won't mind between
this and Polar Express I'm thinking we
need to add don't board a magical train
to the North Pole to the child's safety
list along with don't talk to strangers
and always knock before entering your
parents room on a Saturday morning and
the occasional Tuesday evening
[Music]
what you wouldn't be sneezing if you
weren't cold uh-huh that must be why I
sneeze every pollen season because I'm
cold really some rock solid logic there
Uncle Frost someone the little freight
train stopped to let an expression full
of happy Christmas Travelers pass why
would you stop to let something pass
behind you
hey Bob you're the Foley expert what is
falling clumps of snow sound like have
you tried dropping a bowling ball into a
pile of pots and pans perfect that's why
you're the best Bob but the woods to
which they traveled was still bitterly
cold which the narrator has to tell you
because the animators opted to avoid
turning Karen into a lovely shade of
death blue oh hey there everyone I bring
you Tidings of great joy for unto you I
bring this day a frozen dead child
[Music]
this works
a campfire well isn't that all snug and
come
blows out a campfire no for [ __ ] sake
plan out your sign lettering it's not
like the IES of the last word was a
surprise that you didn't see coming and
when they didn't find frosty and Cameron
on the hill
Santa followed Frosty's Pat in the snow
to the greenhouse it's real real sad
that Karen and frosty forgot to use the
unlocked door to get out an unavoidable
tragedy for sure Karen's reflection in
the frosty juices doesn't move even
though she does also why do Karen and
the hat have Reflections but the pipe
doesn't cast one at all is it a vampire
pipe oh this is about to get good this
Frosty and memorium flashbacks on for
some time all right who left the frosty
puddle set to Rave mode Jelly Buzz
pickle sick Greg it'll turn into
Christmas snow all over again Santa's
doing a real good job of explaining how
Christmas snow will return and all but
there is zero mention of the importance
of the magical hat yeah it'll snow again
but that isn't what brings Frosty to
life Frosty reclined every year with the
magical Christmas snow except it's the
hat that makes him alive we just talked
about this bye Santa thanks for dropping
me off on a very dangerous roof with
loads of snow and ice no way down enjoy
flying into the Bruce Almighty Moon
foreign
[Music]
happy birthday the Hat has five petals I
mean six petals five six four no six
five six four no five four six four five
four six or five or six or five or six
or you know what just add them all up
hey kids you wouldn't happen to have a
cup of warm water would you did you know
the cinemas and writers have podcasts
check out sin cast and behind the scenes
by searching for CinemaSins wherever you
listen to podcasts I'm gonna take
Dorothy slide her into the center of the
deck
and put her back in my pocket
now punch me in the face Frosty it is
Frosty
and there was much rejoicing
oh
Frosty
chase down
the best day of my life and quite
possibly the last
[Applause]
come on Mr Frodo I can't carry it for
you
but I can't carry you and just what are
you going to do about it
[Music]